Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So it was recently brought to my attention that if you search for my name on Google, the very first video result is a video
You made in 2011, Hank, called John Green is an idiot. Now, don't get me wrong. It's a great video
It's just not necessarily the first video I want associated with my name, so today
I thought I would try to replace that video by making a video in which I answer questions that people asked Google about me
Beginning with: Is John Green dead?
No, well, actually, I guess it depends on when you're watching this but not currently.
Where did John Green live? Does! Does! Where does John Green live? I am alive.
I live in Indianapolis where my books The Fault in Our Stars and Turtles All The Way Down are set. Before that I lived in
Chicago where part of an Abundance of Katherines is set and before that I lived in Birmingham
Alabama where Looking for Alaska is set and before that I lived in Orlando
Florida where Paper Towns is set. I am NOT given over to acts of geographical imagination
What books did John Green wrote? I guess we're just living in a world without verb tenses
I wrote the books listed above as well as half of Will Grayson Will Grayson and one-third of Let It Snow. When did John Green
publish his first book? 2005. Look at that little child trying to be serious for his author photo. Are John and Hank Green related?
Yes, we are brothers and no, there are no other siblings. Well, except for Dave
But we don't talk about Dave. Is Hank or John Green older?
I'm just gonna revel in the fact that that's a question people have asked Google. Is John Green a Hufflepuff?
I am, quite proudly I might add. What is the meaning of DFTBA? It's an initialism for several phrases including
Don't Forget To Be Awesome and Darling, Fetch The Battle Axe. And also Dave: Forgotten Through Brotherly Adventures. Is John Green married?
I am. Does John Green have a child?
I actually have two. Does John Green have a podcast? I also have two of those. Is John Green banned from Canada? No
But I do have to go through extra screening when entering Canada because I am on a list of potential
Undesirables due to the fact that I was denied entrance to Canada in 1995 for "insufficient funds"
What is John Green's cameo in The Fault in Our Stars movie?
Right, so my cameo was cut from the movie because I am a terrible actor.
That noted, the scene is available as a DVD extra and also on YouTube. Does John Green have a Hollywood star?
A John Green does but he is not me
He was a composer who won five Academy Awards for scoring such movies as an American in Paris and West Side Story, although today
He is mostly
Forgotten which is a nice reminder that no matter what you do the tides of time will wash away your sandcastle
So there's no sense in reaching for some foolhardy notion of immortality when there's real work to be done with real people right now
But what were we talking about?
Right, no. I don't have a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame. Which John Green book should I read? I mean
I'm a little biased, but I think you should read all of them. Is John Green writing a new book? Possibly,
But it's hard to know for sure. Does John Green like soccer?
Yes, enough to sponsor a third-tier English soccer team, which by the way over the weekend might have avoided relegation
By coming back from two-nil down at half-time to win 3-2 on the last kick of the game! I wept.
I'm not embarrassed to say it. I cried like a baby. Henry said,  "Why are you crying, isn't it happy?"
Yes, it's happy
What kind of music does John Green listen to. I listen to the early stuff from the mountain goats and also the more recent stuff
by the mountain goats.
What is a nerdfighter John Green? So Hank and I have been making videos here at vlogbrothers for more than 11 years and the people
In the community that's grown up around these videos call themselves nerdfighters because they fight for intellectual engagement and celebrate unironic
enthusiasm. Did John Green won
Any awards? My books have won a Prince Award and an Edgar Award but most prestigiously an
MTV Movie Award.
If I just get four more of these maybe I'll get one of those Hollywood stars. Did John Green start at VidCon? This can't
Go on any longer. I just need to leave some quick feedback for Google: VERB TENSES
I technically co-founded VidCon
but only because I was on the phone with my brother when he came up with the idea. Actually that's true for most of the
Stuff we've made together like when I look at my Wikipedia page
I mostly just think, man look at all these things Hank did while I was writing books.
Okay, if you have any other questions, please leave them in comments. I'll answer as many as I can. Hank,
I will see you on Friday.